before we say goodbye we like to play a
quick round dog truth or dare
okay audrey han
yeah
hi audrey hi
hi ross i'm so excited to be here and to
meet you guys in person you are so
pretty with like the best style thank
you so much these little cheery earrings
oh my that's the cherry on top of the
sundae right there that's cute
all right what's it going to be a drew
or dare it's going to be a juice okay so
what's one thing that you love to do is
there were zero consequences
[Laughter]
mine's so boring do you wanna know truly
what it is it's really the honest truth
is i would eat like all the pizza i
could
because i broke up with pizza it was a
great thing while it lasted but i am not
doing it anymore and i just haven't
eaten it in so long and because the
consequences i'm allergic to it it makes
my body swell you understand
i mean do you guys know the movie
defending your life it's an albert brook
it's so meaningful it's just one of my
favorite all-time movies and in it when
they go into the you know purgatory
um basically you get to eat anything you
want without gaining any weight yeah
yeah that's the dream yeah so i not to
be boring but i might piggyback on you
yes very more if i could eat without
consequence
that's all i want yeah that would be the
dream my metabolism is that of a sloth
on a very heavy dose of value
and it's just that sloth is like a sleep
at the switch i eat one donut and i've
got like a giant donut popping out of my
skin if i smell a cheese puff 10 pounds
totally i am like a human pendulum so
eating without consequence would be
everything you need pizza first i know
you can guess my first food mac and
cheese that's right
great question great question thank you
now i have something to dream about
[Music]
you